foreign
people that looked at it and we had one
offer that we were about to accept
on March 2nd and based on the fact that
we were going to to accept that offer I
had a couple of Windows that had some
small chips in it so I was going to go
ahead and fix that so that would not be
a deterrent to executing the sale so on
March 2nd I sent a handyman over to
repair those windows at 7 A.M that
morning after he had picked up the key
he gives me a rather panicked phone call
and said Patty there is a mother Pit
Bull with 10 to 14 babies sleeping on
the front porch and I can't go in the
house
well I had no idea whether why there may
be a dog on my house for sale
so I drove over there and sure enough
there was a dog with with babies and at
that point I was just incredibly puzzled
and so I started to open the back door
with my key and at that point it dawned
on me that the house could have people
in it and that I might place myself in
danger if I simply walked into the house
so instead of opening the back door I
dialed 9-1-1 and had a conversation with
the police and explained the situation
as I was walking around to the front of
the house to wait for the police I think
the tenants must have heard my voice the
squatters rather
must have heard my voice and they came
out
and it was two young women who told me
that they had a lease to live there and
very quickly
she pulled up the lease on her phone
shows it to me it was unsigned as I
could see it and it was issued by a
person whom I didn't know
and so I told her I said I'm really
sorry to tell you this but this house is
not for rent this person has no
affiliation with me or my business
partner the owner of the home and I'm
really sorry I think you must have been
scammed and she told me then and showed
me a receipt that they had paid Thirty
One hundred dollars in first month of
rent pet fee and a deposit and then she
indicated that it was for rent on Zillow
well I own the listing on Zillow and so
it was I knew that it was listed for
sale and had anything been altered on
that you get an email from Zillow saying
that your listing's been altered I had
not had received anything like that I
then looked it up on Zillow and it was
not for rent
so I'm beginning to get a little bit
suspicious but
we're waiting on the police officer and
he indicated that he was pretty sure
that this young woman Was a Serial
squatter because she had just been
evicted from another house not very far
away three or four blocks away
in the past month she had moved into
that house in December and had recently
been evicted so at that point in time we
knew that this was probably a a scam
that these young women run and they go
from one home to another but they know
the law so well they know that I have
absolutely no right to remove them until
it meanders through the civil court
system but that second day I drove by
and I saw that the front door was open
and so I stopped I was alone and I
walked up to the sun room porch and the
dogs were gone so I was feeling rather
hopeful because that front door was
three quarters of the way open so I
knocked I announced my presence
in keeping with the fact that they have
a right to privacy and then I entered
the sunroom porch and knocked on the
front door as well and announced my
presence at that point in time when I
looked into the front door I see that
they're still there I had pepper spray
in my hand they rushed to the front door
and it immediate immediately escalated
you don't have any right to be in
according to my lease me and my
girlfriend owns the house so I don't
know what you need to take up with the
police you know what whatever the case
may be I own the house but yeah okay
okay no no I'm not touching you mom you
are touching me and this lady
God damn it
and then they threw me out onto the
porch and I fell out onto the sun room
porch uh I called the police
uh the police
told me that I had absolutely no right
to privacy that they had if they wanted
to they could have arrested me for that
action another altercation we were
driving by night they threw a brick at
my car and damaged it and we had the
window part way down and they threw
human feces into the car
of course the case went our way but it
didn't go our way until 34 days later
and I had to hire an attorney that cost
me about fifty five hundred dollars in
attorney's fees as well as Court filing
fees and meanwhile the swatters are
living in the house and I have
absolutely no right to go into this
house because these squatters have the
expectation of privacy even though the
law knows that they're squatters
I know that they're squatters and they
know they're squatters they did thirty
eight thousand dollars worth of damage
to the inside of the home purely out of
spite and anger they destroyed walls and
cabinets they stole our washer dryer
they placed feces on the carpet and
other places they left food they threw
eggs on the walls and the the flooring
to add insult to injury we lost that
offer of course that had been made on
the home so it has cost us an enormous
amount of money and time and emotional
energy
I I am concerned from a financial
standpoint as well these homes that we
own a few of them and this is my
retirement and so uh any sort of of
income that I was trusting to live off
of for this year is diminished because
of this act of of stealing that's
essentially what they've done they've
stolen my home from me for a period of
time and then they escalated it by doing
almost forty thousand dollars worth of
damage it is now my decision to get rid
of all of my rental properties and I
will have to figure another way out to
subsidize my retirement this is people
that are taking advantage of Open Homes
and breaking in and using it for their
own living Governor DeSantis needs to
have a special ruling for someone that
breaks into a home whether they have a
fraudulent lease or they've simply
broken in with no paperwork and there
needs to be a far more expedited way
that the court system can look at the
situation and declare quickly within a
couple of days whether or not that is a
legitimate individual in that house who
might have been defrauded by a a
landlord a sneaking landlord or if in
fact it's the landlord that is being
defrauded by a spotter there must be a
differentiation between squatters and
tenants and a more expedited way to
determine if someone has entered your
house if they are a legal tenant